[Applause]
it's
monday everyone which means it's time
for
and now gutfeld presents the dumbest man
in america the crime is rising
my gosh it's so bad i had a great dinner
in new york city tonight the president
is a racist and he is a demagogue so
over the past six months americans have
seen the largest increase in traffic
deaths since we began tracking them 40
years ago back when cat was only 5.
here's how the lemon head sees it 38
680 deaths on u.s roads last year the
most fatality since 2007 and that's even
with pandemic precautions drastically
reducing the number of drivers on the
road so what gives
well some experts are saying that this
is due to an overall lack of civility in
our society a lack of civility that we
have seen in school board meetings over
mask mandates and on airplanes
which again raises the question did lo
don lemon get any oxygen at birth
where was he born on the moon
uh yes some experts are blaming lack of
civility the kind of incivility you see
at school board meetings or over mass
i wonder who he could be talking about
yeah all those car accidents must be
caused by angry parents or conservatives
upset over attacks on their civil
liberties that's the biggest stretch
since dana perino tried to open a car
door
but thank god for some experts and their
mysterious data that evidence is harder
to find than a cnn viewer so i guess the
traffic fatalities couldn't have
anything to do with the reduction of
police on the streets or less
enforcement of traffic infractions i
mean just thinking that would make you
as racist as those guys who beat up
justice millet
look i was someone who drove during the
pandemic
actually i was being driven and i gotta
say killmead looks great from behind
but one thing was obvious there were
fewer cars on the road and like brian
stelter with an unsupervised half gallon
of mint chocolate chip people on the
road took advantage of it
it had zilch to do with civility and
everything to do with opportunity
traffic laws became polite suggestions
but expecting lemon to understand
incentives and disincentives is like
expecting tyrus to fit into my leather
chaps
it's not happening without a lot of
olive oil
still not happening i know i can dream i
don't care what she says yes
but it's funny watching professor stupid
admitting there's a cri crime wave after
a year or so of denying the same crime
wave just three more weeks until 2021
comes to a close but it's already going
down as a year with a soaring number of
homicides all across the country the
murder rate in some cities breaking
records experts say that stress from the
coveted pandemic definitely playing a
role here but the major factor
guns cat drunk dialing makes less wrong
calls
yeah it's the pandemic causing the crime
because when you're forced to wear a
mask you might as well rob somebody at
gunpoint right and yeah it's the guns
behind the violence because the pandemic
has been able to cause guns to get up on
their tiny little gun feet and pull
their own triggers with their tiny
little gun hands
i call it the alec baldwin effect
[Applause]
sorry as red state points out no changes
to gun laws occurred during this time
frame and the overwhelming majority of
gun crimes are committed with illegally
obtained weapons
so the real reason for the crime wave
rests on the shoulders of jackasses like
lemon he like his putrid peers in the
media played down the crime wave as it
emerged and even made fun of the people
who were sounding the alarm which
allowed the wave to grow unfettered so
do we really have to play that tape
again greg
yes we really have to play that tape
again greg
democratic cities are in chaos right now
is this what you want from joe biden and
they're going to take your country away
and they're taking down the statues and
crime is rising
oh my gosh it's so bad you listen to
conservative media you would think that
you know
entire cities are just you know enrolled
in fights and fires and whatever we went
out had a great dinner in new york city
tonight people actually walked up to us
and said thank you for i watch you every
night
well like the olson twins that hasn't
aged well
by the way what the hell is going on
over at cnn first you got that tubin guy
then you got cuomo
now cuomo's producer gets arrested for
allegedly trying to seduce children have
you seen that story it's as sick as sh
they're gonna have to change their
slogan to the most busted name in news
their roster has more deviants than
jeffrey epstein's black book
anyway i tell chris wallace that maybe
this is not the best time to go to cnn
sorry
it's like being on the patriots and
asking to be traded to the jets
but apparently he's going to their
streaming platform
let's hope streaming means what i think
it means
you never know over at cnn
and what a surprise instead of doing a
segment of the on the alleged pedophile
in their midst cnn's fabricating fart
pillow uses wallace to deflect
chris wallace is one of the uh you know
the journalists that is at fox who
stands out like a sore thumb because the
network has become more and more more
radicalized both in the trump years and
now in the biden
years wallace sticks out like a sore
thumb
that's an unoriginal metaphor captain
jowls
it's been used more times than your
waffle iron
you should have said chris wallace
sticks out like my belly when i undo my
bathrobe after dinner
and fox is radicalized if only weight
watchers could radicalize you brian
the corpulent crumb sucker also seemed
to avoid chris cuomo's scheme to smear
our very own janice dean allegedly
calling her that fox weather [ __ ] in
texts after she criticized chris's
brother for transferring covet patients
to nursing homes so we referred to janus
as that weather [ __ ] how stupid is that
everyone knows that's al roker's
nickname
when asked how she felt about being
called that janice said hey at least
it's not fredo
but the fact is the media can't
accurately report on anything whether
it's perversions or fatalities since
they're always implicated in them
while deaths spiked they buried them
because they championed policies and
ideas that contributed to that they
lauded defunding the police and then
they tried to camouflage it by saying
it's really just a funding shift it's
like planting a bush in front of a
septic tank they tried to hide the
consequences of their destructive
beliefs they supported no cash bail
while championing the shutdowns turning
the city streets into a john wick sequel
minus the freedom but as long as lemon
could have a nice evening meal outside
none of the consequences exist you
should never believe the murder rate if
a cnn anchor just ate a good sirloin
now we have record high murder rates in
major cities run by liberal mayors we
have soaring traffic accidents we have
an explosion in hate crimes which forces
lemon to switch from lying to blaming
something vague and unprovable but hey
it's the closest to honest that he's
been in years
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else